the president of Michigan State
University is stepping down over the
Larry Nasser sexual abuse scandal the
former Olympic doctor was sentenced to
40 to 175 years in prison yesterday
NASA admits sexually abusing women and
girls while working for Michigan State
and USA Gymnastics Michigan State
President Lou Anna Simon was under
growing pressure to resign she said in a
statement last night to the survivors I
can never say enough that I am so sorry
that a trusted renowned physician was
really such an evil evil persons under
the front-page headline courageous this
morning's Detroit Free Press lists every
victim that gave an impact statement in
court more than a hundred and fifty
women and girls confronted Nasser before
his sentencing dr. Jon LaPook has
covered this story for more than a year
John good morning good morning Nora in
2016
Rachael den Hollander spoke to the indie
star about Larry Nasser's abuse in that
article she became the first Nasr victim
to publicly disclose her identity a
prosecutor said yesterday the case would
never have gotten to this point if it
weren't for her
Larry sought out and took pleasure in
little girls and women being sexually
injured and violated because he liked it
the case against Larry Nasser began with
Rachel den Hollander and on Wednesday it
ended with her too
how much is a little girl worth how much
is a young woman worth for Judge
Rosemarie aqua Lena it is my honor and
privilege to sentence you Nasser's
victims were worth up to a hundred and
seventy five years in jail I've just
find her death warrant
just before sentencing Nasser spoke
directly to his victims an acceptable
apology to all of you it's impossible to
write and convey but his apology did not
sit well with Aqua Lena who counted it
by reading a letter Nasser gave her last
week I was a good doctor what I did in
the state cases was medical not sexual
hell hath no fury like a woman scorned
day after day one by one Nasser's
victims confronted him in court but many
like sterling wreaths men also took on
Michigan State University USA Gymnastics
and the US Olympic Committee Michigan
State where do you stand us AG and the
USOC
where do you stand Larry Nasser did not
arise in isolation after sentencing den
Hollander also placed blame on the
institution she believes helped protect
Nasser we saw the worst sexual assault
scandal in history unfold because a
predator was left in power for decades
despite warning signs
despite red flags despite direct reports
of assault the US Olympic Committee says
there will be an independent third-party
investigation into itself and USA
Gymnastics it is calling on all current
USA directors to resign u.s. AG
applauded Nasser sentence and said it
supports an independent investigation